bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 9 juin 2015
il est l'heure de retrouver ce nouveau
journal d'actualités locales
d'information locale sur téléphiles dont
voici les principaux titres depuis 2006
movéo mobilise les acteurs de
l'automobile chaque année les mauvais
odeurs permettent de dresser un bilan et
de définir de nouvelles perspectives
c'était aujourd'hui à poissy l'ump
disparaît et fait place au party les
républicains derrière le changement de
nom quelles conséquences et surtout qui
pour incarner le programme en 2017
lors de la campagne présidentielle pour
en parler aurore bergé et une opposition
magny les hameaux conseillère nationale
les républicains elle apporte son
soutien à alain juppé et puis après
maurepas c'est à coignières que pourrait
sortir de terre un nouveau multiplexe
les inquiétudes des cinémas de quartier
qui sont en pleine tourmente est la
coupe d'île de france de robotique et
vient de se refermer à mantes-la-ville
une vingtaine d' équipes s'affrontaient
dans les locaux de l'université de
versailles 50 ans et l'équipe de paris
ouest nanterre qu'il l'a emporté le
troisième prix revenant à l'école
d'ingénieurs yvelinoise en charge
l'organisation elle liste i l'objectif
est de réaliser de toutes pièces un
robot le plus rapide et le plus précis
possible avant qu'il ma complice toute
une série d'épreuves
on reste dans l'innovation avec elle la
recherche et le développement au service
de la mobilité de demain c'est le thème
du mauvais audet qui s'est tenue
aujourd'hui au forum
armand peugeot à poissy nous en avons
rencontré les principaux acteurs un
sujet de florane parfait
recharger sa voiture électrique grâce à
une remorque ce sera bientôt possible
ce produit de l'entreprise chinoise
basée à poissy b tender étaient
présentés aujourd'hui au mot vod il a pu
être développé grâce à l'aide de mauvais
au mauvais lot c'est un pôle de
compétitivité qui favorise l'émergence
de projets innovants
l'existence de ce type 2 de forums et de
kloster est très important et puis nous
verrons nous a aidés également sous
l'angle de la labellisation notre projet
pour aider à accéder à des financements
et véhicules électriques applications et
logiciels intelligents ou logiciels de
simulation 24 produits innovants du
secteur de la mobilité sont mises à
l'honneur
ils sont parfois étonnants comme ce
simulateur de logiciels élaboré à
versailles il est configuré pour aider
les constructeurs à faire évoluer leurs
véhicules sur les problématiques de
consommation et de sécurité aujourd'hui
on va vraiment un marché qui est
en train de devenir de plus en plus
important on a des capteurs à bas coûts
comme la caméra l'ultrason le radar qui
sont déjà de plus en plus présents dans
le véhicule et on a un potentiel qui
reste assez élevé en termes de d'autres
membres de perception un des 24 projets
présentés se verra remettre ce soir une
récompense un mobility à ward
une façon d'encourager la démarche
d'innovation de ses entreprises en
adéquation avec les objectifs fixés par
le gouvernement
nous voulons montrer que les pôles de
compétitivité ça fonctionne et que l'on
passe vraiment du projet de r&d aux
produits sur le marché et donc ses lacs
ce qu'on a voulu donner aujourd'hui à
cette journée en montrant les produits
issus des projets de r&d initié grâce à
mauguio et grâce à l'interaction
l'écosystème d'innovation animé par le
pôle des innovations diffusé bientôt
très largement pour les particuliers ou
les professionnels depuis neuf ans 375
projets ont déjà été labellisé par le
pôle dont 50 % ont obtenu des
financements publics
invité ce soir de ce journal aurore
bergé bonsoir à vous êtes élue
d'opposition les républicains ont
dorénavant à magny les hameaux
conseillère nationale de cette formation
vous étiez en charge de la refonte des
statuts du numérique et l'ump qui n'est
plus les républicains c'est un nouveau
nous c'est une formation à part entière
en d'autres termes est ce qu on a
uniquement changer l'emballage et
j'espère pas à d'ailleurs on a été un
certain nombre à écrire une tribune
juste en amont de ce changement de nom
pour espérer que ce soit pas juste ça
c'est à dire qu'on sort d'une grave
crise à l'ump
maintenant donc on a changé ce nom on ne
s'appelle fut l'ump mais les
républicains où on avait un parti qui
était assez sclérosé on avait un manque
de renouvellement
on avait une absence de parité on avait
un manque de décentralisation aussi du
parti qui faisait que toutes les
décisions finalement été prise à paris
et qu'on écoutait assez peu ce qui se
passait dans les départements alors
qu'en général ils étaient mieux géré que
la manière dont deux parties centrales
on va dire et à gérer tout ça ça doit se
mettre en oeuvre et ça doit se mettre en
oeuvre avec l'objectif des primaires qui
va avoir lieu le 20 novembre 2016 mais
tout ça a changé en quelques jours le
fait de changer de nom ça a tout changé
à l'ump maintenant avec les républicains
à tout va mieux alors je dis pas que
tout va mieux ces partis mais puisque
les rosés par exemple non mais disons
qu'on a eu toute une démarche aussi de
refonte des statuts vous lisiez moi j'ai
participé dans cette commission
nationale des statuts je travaille
notamment sur les questions du numérique
auprès nathalie koscusko morizet l'idée
qu'elle avait c'était déjà d'obtenir la
parité autant au sein des instances
nationales
ce qu'elle a obtenu et je peux vous dire
que c'était pas gagné et elle a obtenu
surtout qui a un parti plus
décentralisée et compris financièrement
c'est à dire que maintenant les
différents départements ce qu'on appelle
nous des fédérations pour avoir des
contrats d'objectifs de réunions
organisées de mobilisation de cartes à
faire et en fonction des objectifs
réalisés ou non les joueurs ont plus ou
moins de moyens donc ça c'est plutôt une
prime au mérite c'est à dire que c'est
aussi se mettre en accord avec ce qu'on
prône on n'arrête pas de prôner le
travail le mérite il faut mettre en
place au sein du parti
la refonte qui a été menée par nicolas
sarkozy savoure
1 vous étiez venu sur ce plateau
d'ailleurs le défendre pour qu'ils
deviennent dans votre formation
j'ai aucun problème à le dire moi je
pense qu'il fait moi je voulais aller au
bout d'un engagement que tu es un
engagement militant au côté de nicolas
sarkozy et j'estimais que c'était
légitime après deux ans de fracture très
forte au sein du parti qui a failli
complètement disparaître
je trouve légitime que nicolas sarkozy
en reprennent la tête il est aujourd'hui
président du parti maintenant il va
falloir qu'il prouve qu'il sait
organiser ce parti et qu'il celle
organisée de manière suffisamment
solides pour qu'on mène efficacement les
primaires en novembre 2016 c'est à dire
qu'avant vous lui faisiez pleinement
confiance c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
à nyon au siège de réserve aujourd'hui
parce qu on aurait pu on voit on va
venir à ce soutien que vous apportez à
alain juppé que dans le cadre de la
primaire
on aurait pu imaginer que vous souteniez
plus tôt nicolas sarkozy justement dans
l'idée de fédérer de rassembler mais je
pense je voulais que la question
justement du rassemblement et de
l'apaisement qui doit exister non
seulement dans le parti mais surtout
dans ce pays la personne qui est le
mieux à même la mieux à même pardon de
les réaliser ça s'appelle alain juppé
aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me suis engagé à ses côtés
que j'ai intégré son équipe de campagne
voilà un mois c'est un choix personnel
j'ai eu un choix militant auprès nicolas
sarkozy depuis que tu es responsable des
jeunes de ce département 2005 jusqu'à
son élection là à nouveau à la
présidence d'abord de l'ump puis des
républicains en 2015 pendant dix ans je
l'admets et je les fais avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé je pense qu'on est allé
au bout finalement d'une séquence d'un
cycle et que la manière dont il a
commencé à engager sa campagne le fait
qu on restreint aujourd'hui encore un
peu trop je trouve ce parti où on fait
entrer des gens qui sont plus d'une
certaine frange une droite qui moi me
correspondent pas peut-être qu'elle
correspond à d'autres personnes mais moi
je trouve pas ma place donc cette déçu
un peu de ce qui a été fait moi je
trouve par rapport aux engagements du
début du mois ce qui était important
c'est qu'on ouvre le parti et je trouve
qu'on ouvre paraît qu'on leur être ici
pendant la première convention des
républicains qui est fait est une
convention sur l'islam
je suis pas sûr qu'on envoie un bon
signal
à l'extérieur du parti même à ceux qui
ont adhéré quand en campagne enfin de
fait déjà pour les primaires nicolas
sarkozy une de ses premières sorties
parle des repas de substitution dans les
cantines encore une fois je pense que
tout ça sont pas des bons signaux et que
c'est pas comme ça qu'on pourra poser
des questions fondamentales que sont
justement les questions de laïcité et la
capacité à réformer ce pays
alors qui pour représenter la droite en
2017 lors de l'élection présidentielle
c'est notre question du jour voici
quelques-unes de vos réponses
je me suis pas posé la question
ça me semble un peu prématuré bas
sarkozy parce que c'est le chef de file
du parti républicain
on va moi j'aurais bien juppé il a un
peu plus de classe que le sarkozy
mon avis les sarkozystes le jeune fu lui
plaît plutôt bras pour changer on a déjà
connu sarkozy une fois deux fois c'est
peut-être pas utile
ouais je verrais bien alain juppé mais
je pense qu'on aura sarkozy ils
proposent de bonnes choses limiter les
revenus des députés enfin
limiter leur nombre leurs émoluments
chaud c'est une très bonne chose ça
ferait des grosses économies pour la
france
je suis assez mitigé pour l'instant je
suis un peu sur le soleil darde bruno le
maire je j'adhère totalement à ce qu'il
a ce qu'il dit il me paraît tout à fait
convaincant c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment le meilleur
voilà bruno le maire pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas en effet où il était venu
me soutenir en plus pendant ma campagne
à manille donc moi je m'entends bien
avec lui et c'est vrai qu'il a instauré
ce il a k'un peut capter ce terme de
renouveau en politique il est bien
entouré pour l'incarner après je pense
que le renouveau sera surtout celui des
idées et aujourd'hui alain juppé il
travaille va sortir en septembre tout un
programme sur l'ensemble des sujets
d'éducation et je pense que c'est plutôt
de ça dont on a besoin on entendu dans
le micro trottoir bon ça sera nicolas
sarkozy parce que c'est le chef de file
du parti même si le téléspectatrices qui
s'exprimait disait on aurait préféré un
juppé mais bon c'est nicolas sarkozy
ça veut dire que les primaires c'est pas
encore quelque chose d'acquis mais rien
est acquis c'est une campagne où le
bureau politique se soit pour le riz
première secrétaire du parti socialiste
c'est n'est pas elle qui a gagné les
primaires du parti il me semble donc
voilà ce sont des primaires ouvertes moi
ce que j'ai envie de dire à ceux qui
nous regardent c'est que vous n'avez pas
besoin d'avoir votre carte dans un parti
politique pour venir voter à ces
primaires elles seront ouvertes et elles
ne seront réussies que si on a à peu
près le même taux de participation que
celui des primaires socialistes à dire
plus de deux millions de personnes voire
peut-être même 3 millions de personnes
pour que ce soit significatif
clairement aujourd'hui il ya un match
quelque part qui s'engage entre nicolas
sarkozy et alain juppé qui sont les deux
candidats les plus à même de remporter
cette élection dont le meilleur il ya
d'autres noms il ya d'autres endroits
sales et a dit que jusqu'au morizet
notamment mais il me semble quand même
qu'aujourd'hui
le match va être entre ces 2 1 et entre
deux visions différentes et des
pratiques et des manières de faire de la
politique est aussi un certain nombre de
sujets qu'ils ont envie de mettre en
avant voilà un jus baisse son premier
thème c'est pas une convention sur
l'islam c'est des propositions sur les
sujets ni ducation tout à l'heure on a
évoqué ce qui avait changé en levêque le
passage vers les républicains de l'ump
il ya des choses qui ne changent pas il
ya toujours des tensions entre les
personnes aussi alain juppé qui a été
copieusement sifflé lors du congrès
fondateur des républicains et puis il ya
eu également alain juppé françois fillon
bruno le maire xavier bertrand qui ont
écrit une lettre à nicolas sarkozy pour
demander lors du bureau politique de ce
soir des clarifications dans le cadre de
la primaire des choses qui ne changent
pas il y aura toujours des tensions
c'est inhérent à la vie politique les
tensions on peut le regretter mais ça ça
changera pas on peut dire en permanence
renouveau renouveau la compétition fait
que ça génère et il ya des petites
phrases aussi à l'honneur de bordeaux
qui a dit que nicolas sarkozy
quelquefois ferait bien de d'arrondir ya
des façons de dire les choses c'est ce
qu'il a déclaré à propos de certaines
déclarations justement quand il est
interrogé est ce que vous feriez pareil
à ce que vous diriez pareil il est bien
obligé de répondre oui ou non
et en l'occurrence ils ont ça ne vous a
pas échappé deux styles qui sont très
différents après sur la lettre qui a été
envoyée à nicolas sarkozy et qui est
cosigné des quatre candidats aujourd'hui
déclarés à la primaire autre que nicolas
sarkozy
ce qu'ils demandent c'est juste que en
effet le parti se met en ordre de marche
pour organiser de manière efficace et
sereine les élections primaires et puis
après peut être non seulement avec les
républicains mais aussi avec lui d y
voir le modèle vous demandez aussi avec
le modem
moi je pense que tous ceux qui sont
parce que les rapports entre nicolas
sarkozy et françois bayrou sont pas au
beau fixe
il me semble mais après tout ce qu'ils
souhaitent l'alternance aujourd'hui et
qui pensent qu'il ya une alternative
possible à françois hollande devrait
vouloir participer à ces primaires et
permet de créer une dynamique donnée à
un candidat alternatif
donc oui moi j'espère que élus dei et le
modem et d'autres peut-être plus petits
partis pourraient nous rejoindre pour
organiser ensemble ces élections
primaires
les primaires ce sera à novembre 2016
ensuite 2017 pour pour la présidentielle
c'est pas un peu prématuré
des régionales qui vont s'engager pour
la fin de l'année est ce que dans
l'opinion publique on va pas s'y perdre
un peu on va pas encore se dire c'est un
combat de chefs tout simplement
mais la première bataille c'est celle
des élections régionales qui ont lieu en
décembre avec valérie pécresse pour nous
pour l'île de france
donc ça c'est une évidence que la
première bataille celle ci entre
parenthèses avec le congrès des
républicains les discussions ont inventé
ce décret c'est tous les jours sur le
terrain dans tous les départements
franciliens donc je vous assure qu'à la
famille sa campagne pas pour
l'accompagner dans le cadre de la
communication ce qui ressort plus dans
les médias c'est justement ces petites
phrases aussi mais c'est aussi notre
éditorial de faire ressortir talent
hôtel petite phrase vous pouvez sans
sociale eh oui si ce déplacement de
valérie pécresse
oui mais parce que malheureusement c'est
ça aussi que vous retenez le plus
souvent c'est un peu simplificateur vous
pouvez aller sur ton père séparé
régionales là ce qu'il faut c'est
organiser de manière efficace le parti
pour que ces primaires puissent avoir
lieu et honnêtement on a besoin de
jeunes années pour pouvoir les organiser
sereinement ses dix mille bureaux de
vote sur l'ensemble du territoire c'est
des moyens logistiques il faut déployer
c'est aussi un cahier des charges sur
lequel il va falloir s'entendre donc
évidemment ça prend un minimum de temps
il faut ce temps pour que ça se passe de
manière tout à fait sereine merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau nous
refermons à présent cette page politique
pour un mot concernant les rythmes
scolaires après la contestation d'une
partie des enseignants et les parents
d'élèves le maire de la commune de
trappes guy malandain a tranché les
horaires de classe restent inchangées
pour septembre en revanche l'heure du
périscolaire va s'étaler de 15h30 à
18h30 en contrepartie la ville
n'organise plus les études en raison du
manque de qualification des animateurs
et de leur nombre insuffisant à noter
que tu rappes n'est pas la seule commune
à repenser les rythmes scolaires pour la
rentrée ainsi l encours les temps
périscolaires seront regroupés sur deux
après midis en semaine au lieu de 4
cette année
7e art et la guerre des salles qui
reprend la commission départementale
d'aménagement commercial vient de
valider le projet d'un cinéma multiplexe
à coignières il y a quelques jours c'est
la commission nationale qui avait donné
son aval pour un projet du même type
mais du côté de maurepas de cinéma à 500
mètres l'un de l'autre et à kehl et
auxquels il faut ajouter les petites
salles indépendantes chacun petit ou
trouvait son compte le sujet de quatre
nuls à tort boulevard des arpents à
coignières c'est dans cet ancien
entrepôt logistique que le projet de guy
salles de cinéma pour 1200 fauteuil
pourrait voir le jeu
pour un projet porté par ses deux ailes
un indépendant qui possède déjà les
cinémas de poissy saint germain en laye
rambouillet zone de paris-ouest amour
pas sur un terrain en friche en face du
village des loisirs
un autre projet de huit salles pour 1700
fauteuil a été validé un projet porté
par cinémovida un exploitant qui compte
neuf cinéma en france de multiplexe à
500 mètres l'un de l'autre n'est ce pas
trop
même les maires des communes le
reconnaissent le cinéma effectivement
économiquement c'est très difficile ce
sera très difficile
effectivement il faut absolument qu'il y
avait quand même une entente
cinématographique sur le secteur pour
arriver à quelque chose qui soit
raisonnable
arrêtons de faire les choses les uns
contre les autres ça n'a aucun sens je
connais tous dans le même bateau et on
est tous là pour servir nos communes
mais aussi pour créer de la richesse et
crée des emplois et si voilà on s'en va
dans cette guerre de cinéma chacun
perdra finalement des deux côtés des
projets 100 % privé pourtant les élus
montent au créneau pour défendre chacun
leur dossier nous sommes un peu moins
dans un gros multiplex si vous voulez
nous sommes dans un dans un projet qui
est un peu plus avec des salles qui font
sens un peu plus en 150 fauteuil qui
sont moins importantes que maurepas et
nous sommes sur un exploitant
cinématographique qui est très local
également ce projet ça présente
maintenant un lieu de vie ce volet parce
que nous avons effectivement c'est ce
cinéma et puis autour nous avons deux
trois restaurants et 9,9 moyennes
surfaces ou magasins ce qui en termes
d'emploi calculé le maire de coignières
représenterait 140 postes
gregory k restiez rappelle lui que le
projet de cinéma à maurepas date de 1993
il a donc toute sa légitimité
priorité au cinéma ne meurt pas
puisqu'il a été validé en commission
nationale d'aménagement commercial et
que c'est un sujet qui dure depuis des
années et que c'est un beau projet quand
on voit sur les plans que c'est un
cinéma qui est tout en bois qui
correspond à l'identité de la ville de
maurepas moi je défendrai évidemment le
cinéma ne mord pas parce que la survie
du village loisirs en dépend les maires
des deux communes se sont rencontrés ce
lundi pour en discuter
la mairie de maurepas va éditer dans les
jours à venir le permis de construire
car il n'y a plus de
recours possibles concernant le
multiplex dans cette ville à coignières
le maire lui devons maintenant attendre
deux mois le temps que des recours soit
déposé recours qui devrait selon toute
logique être présentée par les opposants
au projet un dossier qui pourraient
empoisonner les relations entre les deux
communes voisines qui doit pourtant
travaillé de concert pour préparer au
mieux leur intégration dans la caisse
qui en janvier prochain
et juste après ce journal vous
retrouverez le 7-8 société consacrée aux
multiplexes justement quel avenir pour
les petites salles émission à regarder
également en ligne sur notre site
internet grâce au replay cinéma toujours
demain mercredi dans les salles
jurassique world le remake de jurassic
park de steven spielberg au delà du film
à gros budget c'est surtout la présence
au casting de l'illinois omar sy qui
intéresse le public de l'hexagone est il
vraiment présent justement dans ce film
rassurez vous il sera en tout cas
beaucoup plus à l'image que dans x men
ont les coûts' d'ailleurs omar sy
c'était lors de l'avant première
mondiale de ce film à paris omar sy
encore émerveillé par sa nouvelle
aventure américaine
je vous dire la chose la plus
surprenante sur ce plateau c'était moi
c'était d'y être ça c'était vraiment
surprenant inimaginable c'est
inimaginable quand le bus geraci part
j'avais 15 ans donc c'était très très
loin de penser qu'un jour je ferai des
films encore moins celui là donc
donc non c'était c'est juste quelque
chose d'incroyable me retrouver sur ce
plateau la faire ce film là c'était
juste dingue déjà d'être sur le plateau
mais je suis encore plus sûr
qu'aujourd'hui maintenant que j'ai vu le
film je vois à le rendu même si je
m'attendais à avoir quelque chose
d'énorme
là le film est vraiment
vraiment content très content très fier
de dos ce moment là
loin du parc des dinosaures le défi
nature à saint quentin en yvelines nous
y revenons une nouvelle fois pour
s'intéresser ce soir à l'aspect santé
les jeunes et les moins jeunes ont pu
tester le canoë l'escaladé au golf ou
encore le vélo mais des stands sur ce
thème donc de la santé et du bien-être
étaient également proposés michael et
demi d'euros william l le défi nature
souffler sa huitième bougie ce week-end
les participants ont pu tester cette
occasion sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines dizaine d'activités
gratuitement au programme de cette 8ème
édition du canoë du tir à l'arc de l'
escalade ou encore du golfe la vocation
c'est de permettre à la population
locale en fait de venir découvrir aussi
les activités qui sont proposées sur
notre territoire et c'est une occasion
particulière de pouvoir venir s'essayer
gratuitement à ces disciplines et puis
pourquoi pas après pratiquer une
entraide régulièrement cette année
l'accent a été mis sur le vélo en
référence aux championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste organisée en février
dernier à saint quentin en yvelines pour
faire découvrir ce sport des parcours
ont été mis en place il ya deux parcours
il ya un parcours pour d'initiation on
va dire donc c'est juste une petite
montée un petit parcours donc très court
pour ceux qui ne maîtrisent pas et puis
à prendre un par contre un peu plus long
avec des virages beaucoup plus serrée et
c'est voilà donc illégaux et le but est
de ne pas mettre le pied au sol bien sûr
j'ai fait parcours 2 me et c'est quoi le
parcours bleu
c'est en fait on doit monter une pente
après on tournait à prendre ont conduit
à tourner on sort mais c'est un peu dur
en fait en parallèle des activités
sportives des stands sur le thème de la
santé du bien-être ont été installés les
visiteurs pouvaient se faire masser
tester leur diabète ou encore connaître
leur niveau
d'activité physique vous avez une fente
question voilà impliqué ici avec
différentes réponses à remplir chaque
mois en fonction de là pour ce que vous
donnez vous allez à un score qui va
s'afficher voilà à la fin ce score m
accumulés et en fonction du score obtenu
vous obtenez une réponse sur un niveau
d'activité physique conséquente en
contrat de travail de ce qu'on fait à
côté du transport comme utiliser plus de
facteurs je pense que c'est bien pour
lier plus pour les adultes en fait voir
par rapport à ce qu'ont fait ou ce qu'on
pense bien faire vous pas bien faire au
total défi nature attiré plus de 800
personnes sur l'intégralité du week end
vu le succès rencontré cette année
événement sera évidemment reconduit pour
une neuvième édition la venue de nicolas
abou accueilli quelques 700 exposants le
week end dernier lors du traditionnel
vide greniers annuel une manifestation
qui a fait le plein forcément de
visiteurs avec le beau temps ambiance
pas mal de choses vous ou purée
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait tout ça alors on
prouvy on met dans le vide greniers mais
aussi on fait du tri on s'est débarrassé
donc voilà donc pas en plus il fait
observer
c'est surtout sur ses on a beaucoup
beaucoup de choses entassés à la maison
et donc l'autre objectif principal c'est
de donner une deuxième vie aux objets
parce que ça nous font le coeur de juste
laisser partir à la poubelle et donc on
passe un bon moment on échange avec les
gens plus de 680 trois exposants sont
venus faire de bonnes affaires et
partager un bon moment en famille
les plus jeunes ont même pu profiter de
différentes animations dont la structure
gonflable qui a eu un réel succès pour
plaire aux beaux parents comme aux
enfants on a installé des structures
gonflables donc toujours énormément de
succès 1 euros les 10 minutes
donc c'est un prix très raisonnable et
est tellement la pêche aux canards pour
les plus petits pour d'autres c'était
également l'occasion de fouiller un peu
et déloger la perle rare tiers des
affaires et puis pour profiter ce beau
temps et puis même manifesté un peu
notre présence sur m'ont dit on flâne on
arrive on arrive toujours à trouver
quelque chose quand même qu'à amener
regarder
rien de particulier le coup de coeur des
choses sympas une journée in montaigne
chaude et ensoleillée qui était
visiblement placée sous le signe de la
convivialité et des bonnes affaires sans
de cette édition prochain journal
mercredi aux horaires habituels
excellente soirée on se quitte avec la
bande annonce de jure aqsiq world qui
sera donc en salles demain mercredi avec
notamment le trappistes omar sy il n'est
pas question de contrôle reste là c'est
une relation basée sur le respect
ces animaux se disent je dois manger je
dois chasse et je dois il ya bien de ces
besoins que vous ressentez aussi
chaque fois que les dévoilant une
nouvelle attraction la fréquentation aux
plantes
et non
la direction a estimé que ces mélanges
génétique boosterait l'effet waouh
ce sont des dinos effet waouh t'es chat
garantie on l'a conçu plus imposante que
le tiraille ce qu'est devenue sa soeur
elle l'a dévoré nous avons un sujet en
or confinement
est-ce que c'est sur ma planche et ps se
les arracher comment était le y penser
c'est rappeler où l'avait posée
elle tue pour le plaisir
vous savez pas mille visiteurs il
n'avait plus de bateaux et pas les armes
nécessaires si on fait ça on fait à ma
manière
racine origine
on allume
un problème et communiquent entre eux
ce n'est jamais qu'un animal
d'une intelligence hors norme
vous